ja gut dann komm mal her komm her
schätzchen kommt papa ich hab noch
witzig jetzt bin ich wieder da ganz
hinten
ich muss irgendwie umbringt macht man
jetzt wieder bei dem gps und so
versteckt hälst du verdammt da hast du
in schalter oder so er habe ich gemacht
hab
dem 7 steht da ist aber game 6 das tier
vorne steckt fest
ein parcours das sind das hier mtf
durchlaufen
durch mehr wir durchlaufen nicht schlimm
so jetzt hier durchs wasser jetzt trinke
ich das natürlich gut
er hasst irgendwas gemacht ich hab gar
nichts gemacht
muss man nun vielleicht her weil hier
das nichts montero hingeworfen
kostet nix da ist irgendwo gerade pisten
angegangen geht da noch mal hoch oder
wartet bleibt du mal im wasser
na gut ich schaff das nicht springen
darüber habe ich komme auch nicht hoch
dunkeln wo pistols angegangen es gerade
extra lange anlauf genommen
nein weil ich kurz gucken was da hinten
ist so warte ich bin jetzt rüber
ok hatte ich bin jetzt aber ich helfe
dir noch ein bisschen
er widerspricht das denn jetzt nicht
mehr was dann ja auch kommen
ich hätte nicht ein bisschen später
abspringen
ich brauche essen haben ich höre ganz
gar nicht ich hab einfach gar kein
minecraft sound das richtig geil
warum keine ahnung ich helfe dir mal ein
bisschen amazon person adventure bisher
nicht so wichtig ausgeschafft jetzt so
nochmal das wasser ja bin drin hatte
irgendwas bleibt beim wasser drin bleibt
aktuell
ich habe dann einen dingels reingeworfen
dass er den gleichen effekten nein wenn
das eine steinbrecher plett ist da ja
ich stehe drauf okay okay man muss
länger drinbleiben gut ich hab's
geschafft
ich bin tot nein diesmal wieder bei den
anderen städten waren nicht auch in
betten warte bei uns am leben dann
telepathie ich mich zu dir
das heißt immer darf nur einmal springen
springt immer okay ich schaffe
wahrscheinlich teleportiert ich zu mir
du kannst noch einfach nach oben klicken
was nach augenblicken pfeiltaste nach
oben springen ich bin nie drin aber ich
bin schon da das ist ein komischer tätig
so ja ok cool jetzt eine tür warum die
da ist weiß ich nicht gleich springt
noch nicht selber nenne ich glaube dass
gerade alter noch zwei sprünge noch ein
sprung geschafft ganz springt dann komme
ich dazu willst du schlechte fertig zu
mir hey ich bin zuerst da geht's nicht
lang das ist die andere seite einfach
martin
hier müssen wir lang so passiert so
etwas getan ok fleisch schalter gedrückt
gibt ich geb dir drei vielleicht komme
ich geb dir gesteckt wo geht's lang
ach da ist die tür von vorhin ok
telepathie ich zu mir herr bradl wieder
zurückspringt wenn man jetzt den
schalter gedrückt hatte kurz auf der
platte hier stehen bleiben
die töne nicht kurz offen im moment denn
da gut
er ist der brauch ich bin der pro es
geschafft aber okay ich versuche selber
gerade mal abgeschafft nein um
abgerutschte hatte immer die npd auf da
steht bei mir im boden wtf ein wenig
jetzt nicht mehr
doch immer noch wissen beim game 7 hätte
raul tft-display paniert bisschen normal
gewusst er ist immer noch klein
hast du gar keine augen war er ab 12
holz batir uni need to do with it play
des crystal lake gold nugget fest
phishing wird er zwölf löcher
er verstehe ich es nicht da sind peter
plates drin und irgendwo ist eine drin
halt und um jedes zu treffen ist da so
eine lücke
du musst halt immer eine andere lücke
dann gehen ach was ich habe eine
gefunden
okay gut ich war ja wie eine gefunden
wie man das nennt man eine hat er das
stück macht achter ist ja kein
geldproblem gut dann komm mal her komm
her schätzchen kommt papa hier sitzt
hier vorne direkt links woher was links
und recht die erste links unten ja gut
das weiß nicht getroffen
immer noch nicht getroffen immer noch
nicht getroffen
das noch nicht nein
jetzt habe ich noch
ich hab so herr bewahrte wasserkuppe
moment hält lass mich mal zu der ecke wo
du da stehst da was kannst du eigentlich
ich gucke ob mit opti feind warte mal
ich hab's ich hab's ich hab' ich hab's
das habe ich gesehen wirklich toll da
kann ich jetzt aufhören damit in der
probe liegt was machst du da eigentlich
die weiß auch gar nicht ob du nett
update getroffen hast da war merkt man
das denn ich hab noch eine so ich hab
jetzt eine hier vorne
wenn man mir die tür auf demnächst quest
hast eine ja auch kurz noch die einer
hier wieder deinstallieren
mst
meine hier die iss an er hat es nicht
auf
bei dir auch ja kein fake pressure plate
das heißt du musst eventuell eine andere
nehmen
doch ist loch kommt die tür offen ist
nach müsste somit den angelruten was
müssen wir mit einer angelrute svec
reifen vorne mache ich guckte drin ist
immer noch nicht aufwarten mal kurz
verschiedener fächer
man braucht nur zwei viele löcher wie
vielleicht hast du martin dass zwei der
nase ein und 2005 popo loch das sind 6
wenig
martin moment ich muss gerade überlegen
doch ganz kalt wir wieder weg profil
überall der mann jedoch ok ich hab' ich
habe wieder eine pritsche plate überdies
falsch
okay da unten sind auf jeden fall
schonmal popel drin das macht jeder
sieht echt erotisch aus wir haben wir
noch eine angel deiner und meine um
eines gleich kaputt
ich weiß dass immer noch auf etwa 200
muss schon treffen denn erstmal gucken
richtig meinte mal ein paar goldner
gesehen wohin in löcher das jetzt
vielleicht irgendwann bringt weil er
alles kaputt warte ich geb dir meine ist
aber noch nicht auf
da ist die angel aber bei der einbrecher
platz hat wirklich dick gemacht gmbh ja
gut ich meine mythen oder irgendwie
passt auf sie es auf sie ist auf mach
ich bin so ein tier presse ich habe
alles gemacht gucke ich habe die melonen
ich hab einen schalter gedrückt dass ich
hab das gewonnen ich nehme das gold auch
nötig aber nur das ganze gold ich okay
cool wie kunst nach oben moment als und
wegen mir ich bin der allerbeste also
ich hab ja mehr gold als du hin bevor
das wieder leute verschenken martin hat
natürlich die quest gelöst weshalb
wirklich auch ein bisschen weiter
darunter moment ach ja hier ist game 9
hier ist game macht auch das ist das mit
la martina wo wir am anfang zu erstmal
bin ich am anfang an falsch gespart und
jetzt muss man irgendwo den schalter
drin finden in den ganzen ton ist dass
irgendwo ein paar minecraft sind ihr
schon ausgebildet geklatscht getratscht
weil wegen minecraft ist blöd und zu
minecraft ist gar nicht blöd weil das
war so verrückt das sound zum glück hab
ich denn nicht das war noch am anfang so
dass wird dabei der 2 einfach nur total
komisch
wenn sie eigentlich vor die mannschaft
stellen bleiben dir vor dem kurz stehen
ich habe dabei doch hier muss selwer
hier sehr offen
martin hier sind sieben münchen darin
dass das zelt geschickt ja ok cool
das heißt wir müssen jetzt kann ich auch
was essen haben
das war cool mit meinem lohn braten
samuel m führt jetzt doch foto lappen
trade center mainz okay weil alles jetzt
meinen gott oh gott wir müssen mein mann
einfach klassische strippt bei big nach
unten vor allem das ist einfach so einen
raum wahrscheinlich macht nach unten
könnt ihr denn sein das weiß ich nicht
okay gut dann machen wir es jetzt
einfach zu zwei abstand meinte ok aber
es könnte theoretisch sein dass der oben
oder unten liegen wo ist aber das ist ja
nur der doch das könnte sein
ach du scheiße ich dort nicht dass der
so weit weg ist
hast überhaupt fackeln
nein also dann kommen wir hin und
gewichte welche ich brauch kein okay
dann ich mache das wie ein richtiger
mann du oh gott das ist ja auch das ist
schon bedrock wo ist der level bau warte
bis du schon am ende ja
die welt ist das ungefähr 1 2 3 4 5
ich hab das eine geheime neuen blacks
gott und wie weit geht es runter runter
geht es nicht wenn auch nicht auch noch
ein okay gut dass wir brauchen könnten
dann glaube ich mich eben kurz zur seite
bis ich wieder bei dir denn hier ist
auch mit rock stehen nicht ich glaub ich
brauch fackeln
ich glaube ich auch ich habe fackel nur
das sehr schön sie ist meinen namen dann
glaubt nicht zu mir hin
hättest du bist du so weit hinten
verdammt ja die redstone better things
jetzt anders gab dich einfach zu mir hin
geht nicht bei mir speedrock